so now imagine that you're a creative
person who's writing Batman
uh now men just go okay well I'm going
to write Batman as I know Batman he's
going to be Batman he's not going to be
me I don't want to put myself into
Batman he's going to be Batman I'm going
to do the best Batman sir I can do
these ladies
Batman starts getting sassy they start
to write Batman with more of their own
traits and soon before you know it it's
like these characters are unrecognizable
they're sitting around having coffee in
bars and having Chit Chat and stuff and
it you know they they they're they seem
to be unable to actually and I'm not
saying all of them there are some ladies
who are great and the Senti shout out
Louise Simonson Great writers but many
of them are just
you know projecting themselves onto
these characters and maybe it's because
they really just don't care that much